new information just exposed that many
of the emotional stories Hassan Minaj
shared on his 2022 Netflix special
King's Jester which includes claims that
he rushed his baby daughter to the
emergency room after opening mail sent
to his house that was filled with poison
which fell into her stroller have
apparently been completely made up by
Hassan in fact according to an article
published by the New Yorker the New York
police department has no record of an
incident like the one Minaj describes
nor do area hospitals wait but Andrew
comedians make up stories all the time
that's true usually we do it to make
things funnier not make things more
racist or sad it's not like he was using
these exaggerations or hyperboles
punchlines he was using them to kind of
make the audience feel worse about him
and then it turns out these things
didn't actually happen he made life
worse for other people in real life